all right my man what's up
of a much big fan
um just wanted to say I appreciate what
you do I I got uh got my debt settled
because of your book and
um you did it all by yourself
yeah I actually called the number you
guys have on your website I'm not sure
who I spoke to but they were nice enough
to help me even though I'm in Los
Angeles and I think I got like a 40 40
um paid off so good stuff man well done
yeah but today's to today's topic
um I found I think you talked about this
on Michael Strahan's podcast but he was
sort of asking about Direction and
purpose and you said you know
eliminating red flags and avoiding the
pitfalls is often a good place to start
and I've definitely noticed that like
eliminating alcohol all of a sudden I
started making better decisions and so
recently
you know I got out of a relationship
with a Becky as you would call it a boss
girl and uh a little older than me
earned more than me and just two years
of a mess and uh you know a month out
I'm doing better in a lot of ways I'm
just sort of curious
when when you've kind of attached your
meaning to the girls a relationship
um and you're looking for you know a
sense of purpose outside of that so you
don't backtrack into it you know fall
off the wagon if you will
um how do you how do you think of that
you know is it I'll show you is it is
there something you know from a messy
question why did you pick Becky why did
you what what did you get into LTR with
a boss girl
attention video as well and so I was
living a pretty adventurous life but
everything kind of came to a halt and
she was very inviting I mean at the time
I think one of the first things I told
her was I'm not the guy you're gonna
marry you know I think I told her like
you look a little expensive and she sort
of laughed at all that
but she ended up inviting me into this
nice house she's she's like a flight
attendant private Chef cooked me all the
meals made a closet for me and it was
going great until we moved to LA and she
you know started getting the DMS invited
to the Yachts plane tickets and uh I
just got caught in that love bomb and
then pull away and I got I spent about a
year simping trying to get it back
um yeah so short answer it was like a
geisha you know all the real things and
then overnight ghosted complete reversal
hold you Devin
I'm 34.
yeah and you're probably in better shape
make more money than you did when you
were 24. absolutely yeah yeah I got a
lot of the boxes checked I could earn a
little bit more
um but yeah I found I I tend to go
codependent even with video partners
with relationships it's like I want to
do somebody else's dream sometimes
especially if it's close to mine but now
that I'm on my own I'm kind of following
that inner voice everything's going
better I just I wanted to know honestly
like I quit alcohol my instinct was quit
relationships for 18 months just have
fun
um because there's not much out here in
La where I can see a value
a value exchange that makes sense for me
um
just looking for you know how you know
maybe how do you think of okay if I'm
not chasing a girl or family or one of
these things like what's what's the big
picture reason well it's let's always do
it it's always boiling down the same
thing for me which is focus on yourself
Chase Excellence not women right like
one of the things that I see a lot of
guys doing I I've done this myself too
right like
you know you see a
a boss girl let's call her Becky right
which is you know what I talked about
last week if you guys didn't watch that
one yet but
she's she's a she's certainly attractive
you know especially to the plugged in
men out there that are that are told
their entire lives you know find your
equal partner you know build a life
together
all that sort of stuff and it's like
okay well somebody that has a good job
in their own place and they have a
decent car that runs and doesn't leak
oil and stuff like that and seems to
have their life together and you walk in
their house and it's like hey this place
is decorated pretty nice and it smells
nice
you kind of like
you know put yourself in there it's like
you're like a piece of the puzzle that
sort of clicks sort of thing and at the
end of the day it's like
you want to be
bigger than that like women are only
happy and content with you in entering
your frame and serving you and being a
confidential life if she can look up to
you
if she can say this guy's the best that
I can do
um other men become an invisible DM show
up and she doesn't respond to them
because she's like whatever you know
this guy's my world I don't see anything
so that's that's what the answer always
seems to boil down to and I get people
say look you know not everybody can be
at the Pinnacle of the pyramid there's
there's a lot more plugged in simps at
the bottom than there are the unplugged
Alphas you know towards the top sort of
thing and they're right but
why like you're not going to soar like
an eagle if you surround yourself with
turkeys right my dad always used to say
this to me
so the answer is always be better you
want better options with women you want
a higher caliber of woman you want a
woman that's more likely to be sticky to
you and not you know wander off just
improve yourself and don't care if she
goes off and bangs Kevin from sales
maybe she was a hoe maybe you just
weren't a good enough guy for
maybe any of those things don't even
matter
forget about the pain forget about the
suffering
just what do you do you know you do
YouTube videos you make camper van stuff
I I don't know but whatever it is that
you do do more of that do it better
collaborate with better people tell
better stories work on your so that
you improve and become better than it's
it's just be better it's just be better
the next day be better the next week
than what you were be better the next
year than what you were before and
that'll give you better options with
women so you don't have those sorts of
problems right
yeah just be better you know growing I I
know that feels better and maybe I'm
thinking too much in terms of like
what's the purpose if I live in Los
Angeles and I don't even want to
entertain the thought of having a kid
out here and exposing myself to all that
um
yeah that's true but like I guess what
I'm asking is you know
purpose outside of you having you know a
kid and that going the way it did you
know starting this YouTube channel
starting a business
um I think I fall for somebody else who
says oh we could have a family or oh you
can help me fulfill my purpose you know
I just
um I was wondering if you even need that
or if you just grow every day and you
kind of stumble into that well men men I
believe having an innate need to find a
woman to to or or women you know
whatever happens you know your angle
may or may not be but
men like women if if you're straight men
like women men like women that are in
their lives men like women that look
pretty and smell pretty and do nice
things to serve them and cook for them
and feed them and take care of them men
like that right
so you want to stay away from that for a
bit cool do it you know but if you like
women you're always going to be drawn
back but it's like if you're always
going to be drawn back why not have
better options why not be in a position
where you can just say oh you know what
you're Bad News Bears go away
I have I have better options and then
you just stop responding
why aren't you talking to me you're not
getting back to me look I'm not
interested sorry goodbye and just you
know you move on sort of thing right
that's all for sure yeah just accept
it's not complex dude like don't like
don't complicate your life unnecessarily
it's it's okay find your purpose work on
your grind you know if you find that
you're struggling in certain areas of
life obstacles you know get in the way
of things you know sometimes the
obstacle can become the way that's it's
basically a book by Ryan holiday the
obstacle is the way
um which is a good read which I'd
recommend but you don't need to suffer
you know pain will come pain will happen
you will make some bad choices debt was
a painful problem for you you you know
you looked at it you said I don't need
to deal with this you found a solution
you paid 40 cents in the dollar now it's
gone right like yeah Europe you're a
problem-solving being you're you're an
ownership guy like that's what guys do
like we take ownership for so lean
into that more lean in the paint don't
amplify the suffering stop telling
yourself you know yourself stories a lot
of guys would just be like well that
chick she just took advantage of me and
I did everything for her and then she
went and banged some guy and a yacht
because he DM like you know that's you
know that's like the victim mindset
that's like the story that you want to
tell to sort of you know keep dealing
with the pain it's like just move on
from it right
cool uh yeah was there was there a point
when um I don't know if you you dealt
with some of this insecurity yourself
was there a point when it just uh kind
of clicked and you're like I don't
overthink it anymore I pretty much found
uh found a
that's that's when you're fully
unplugged my friend that's when you look
at everything and you're just like okay
whatever yeah like you're in a position
to just do whatever you want and not
care yeah you know because you
understand because you know because you
know better because you've experienced
because you've been through it right
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out